the dark Powers want to use symbol in a
way that sort of obfuscates what's
really there powers are always based
when they have a kind of a bent agenda
they have to have some kind of lie
that's inherent to the way they're
working in the symbolic world because
true symbol is integrity between what's
on the inside and what's on the outside
it's it's kind of the way I think about
Glory True Glory is like pure Integrity
of what's on the inside and the outside
like a piece of Amber you know and you
put it up to the Sun and it's just like
this beautiful translucent thing that
you look through and it's solid all the
way through whereas a distorted symbol
and now we get into things like idols
and advertising and and words and
stereotypes and things that kind of like
have a certain Force socially they're
all predicated on some kind of a lie
they have a duplicitous nature they
function precisely because their inside
does not have integrity with the outside
the outside has more of like a
grandiosity which we kind of like almost
attribute to things by virtue of
Association but they're hollowed out
they really don't have integrity of
meaning yeah
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so hello everyone I am very happy to be
here with Ted Lewis Ted Lewis is the
director of the international Jacqueline
Society
Cristiano who you may have seen on this
channel is a good friend of mine
presented us I myself have you know read
some jacquel I I've struggled with
Jacqueline you know in some ways I feel
like his Insight on technology is uh is
very important for us right now to
understand the problem civilization the
problem of Technology but also of course
as an Orthodox Christian and as someone
who makes images I've struggled with
some other aspects of Jacqueline which
is uh what I see as the two negative
vision of the city of civilization of
the image of you know of spatiality and
the kind of the possibility of these
things to manifest in the world today
and so I'm really excited to be able to
kind of engage this discussion uh with
Ted and so Ted thanks for coming along
yeah it's great to join in here
so I
I will know Jackie little but maybe
several will not so could you give
people a sense of who he was what's his
importance for us today
yeah I'll be glad to
uh jacquel uh is
a mid-century thinker and many in many
ways as a Pioneer in the area of
critiquing technology
and his prominent book The technological
Society came out first in 1954 in in the
French Edition 1964 in English
so we're coming up on a 70th year
anniversary
but even before that uh during the Nazi
era Jacques Luol and his friend uh
Bernard Charbonneau and others in the
personalist context in France we're very
concerned about how the force of
technology and a mechanized world would
have an effect on society as well as our
very Humanity so one of the threads
through all of his writings I mean he
wrote a lot 40 books died in 1994 but
the thread through all of that is sort
of a warning
that if Western people do not really
come to terms with how
um the force of progress and Technology
when it's untethered from ethics will
end up having a deep effect on even the
way we conceive ourselves as human
beings
a simple way to think about it is is to
think about how environments influence
us
so a little kind of split things into
three zones there's sort of like a time
where nature was our environment and and
social Villages and and cultural things
are primarily
rooted in how nature forms and patterns
human life
and then the next stage has to do with
just uh what what he calls the
environment of the of the social this is
the society we might think of the Greek
city-state and the Roman world and into
the Medieval World and Renaissance and
the social world
uh has more influence from how humanity
is starting to lift itself away from
nature and to create new new ways of
thinking and being and Science and and
and whatnot
and then for a little technology it's it
itself becomes a third kind of
environment an environment which informs
who we are as people it didn't it it
almost becomes totalistic for him
and some people think he's you know too
too far with that totalistic uh way
about technology as a force dominates
every part of human life
but but those are some broad Strokes
around his writings
yeah well I think the thing that for
myself made me feel close to you is that
he definitely seems to understand
because it's important for people to
understand that ilu was also a very uh
serious Christian you know his his
Insight much of the way that he thought
came from the Bible came from his own uh
he was was he reformed was he Protestant
I don't know what his tradition was yeah
primarily identified with uh with the
French reform and uh had had quite a bit
of influence within France and in those
circles
one of the more more significant things
is but before he was really a Christian
he had read Karl Marx he fully embraced
uh a Marxist approach and in many ways
that continued to inform his his
sociology
and then he starts to read Kierkegaard
uh I think he's known for reading just
about everything Kierkegaard wrote which
is really astounding and then and then
he started getting introduced to Carl
Bart
so Kierkegaard and Bart kind of
Advanced his his Christianity out of a
traditional calvinist reform Zone into
what you might call more of a
dialectical perspective of Faith matters
and so one of the things that impressed
me was that he does seem to really pick
up very much on a clear strain in the
Bible which is the you could call it the
canine image of of civilization which is
that we've we find in the first chapters
of Genesis that Civilization is is an
issue of the descendants of Cain and is
in some ways a a kind of reaction cons
you know reaction to the curse and uh
compensation for the curse in some ways
to to think about that that he seems to
see the city in that that vein and and
civilization and tick tick the
technification of society in this this
kind of uh line let's say canine
and you really have to understand a
lull's critique of the city and he does
come on pretty strong
as a follow-up to Harvey Cox's book The
secular City where Harvey Cox tends to
have more of an open-mindedness like now
now that we've come into uh you know the
fullness of modern society all the
virtues that that might come with that
what a little son that was a
sacralization of the city
so it's not the city per se with all of
its uh architecture and structures and
and
institutions for for a little that's
most problematic it's the fact that it
gets lifted up like a Tower of Babel
as something that becomes autonomous
with its separate law autonomous from
God so that that's really at the heart
of the Louisville's critique of the city
is it becomes archetypal
just like the Tower of Babel of human
Enterprises that don't know how to be
um more
interactive and participatory with with
God in a spiritual realm yeah and in
this way this is where in some ways the
it starts to rub with me in terms of
especially being an Orthodox Christian
is that his
his interpretation of that leads all the
way into his vision for example of image
making and also of liturgy how he saw
liturgy as something similar to this to
this process you know where he tends to
be suspicious of all
of all formalizations you know any type
of formalization seems to be suspicious
and and prone to becoming Idols uh and
his approach seems to be a kind of
desire to de-sacralize or demythologize
you know very much like Karl Barth very
much in that in that sense where in some
ways he sees Christianity as the
ultimate de-sacralizer you could say
that that de-sacralizes everything is
that do you think my understanding is is
right in that
I I think it's it's fairly good and you
have to understand that elul once went
to a Nazi rally
some sometime in the in the later 30s he
was he was at one of those rallies and
he even admitted that he felt the pull
that the magnetism the the the group
energy getting drawn into that and so
his his reaction to ceremony and ritual
and the use of of Arts ultimately has to
be understood through the lens of how it
can be used to manipulate Society
of course he then writes Empire of the
nonsense where he kind of feels like
most modern artist itself sort of um
you know dominated by a technological uh
flow within the 20th century so he
doesn't have a whole lot of positive
things to say about Modern Art
and so what is his view of let's say
because there is an eschatological image
of the city right in in the Book of
Revelation and so how does for himself
like how does he reconcile those images
together well I'm I'm glad you used the
word reconcile because that is a word he
likes to use where image and word come
together in a in a fruitful way
so probably the most important book for
this topic of of his perspective on
images and liturgy and and all of that
is the humiliation of the word
uh it happens to be one of my favorite
uh books and I was able to bring it back
into print recently
and at the end of that book he has a
whole chapter called reconciliation and
by that he's talking about Jesus word of
God
ultimate image of God as reconciling
word and image in a way that restores
the balance of both
and then that has implications then for
other aspects of Christian Life
so even though he's very very hard on
image and he pries his word I mean the
very title the humiliation of the word
is sort of like grieving over the fact
that
um we are an image dominated Society
image saturated
uh and and we prize more what we see
rather than what we hear
and and he goes into great depth about
how the loss of our capacity to hear
well affects
our our thinking or our way of relating
to to the spiritual realm and to God
um and and it kind of roots us much more
in the Here and Now
so bringing back a restoration or
reconciliation of word and image for him
is the pathway modeled by Jesus to to
you know to to bring us into a better
Zone
and so one of the things that made me
fascinated to talk about this is that
recently uh you know gave me this this
wonderful edition of The elul Forum that
deals uh in large part with the question
of how Jacqueline talked about
principalities and Powers this is I
think something which is extremely
relevant today as we're noticing one of
the things that social network the like
social media has done and the internet
has done is that it has accelerated the
question of the relationship between
between attention and the way in which
social forces function and what it has
done is that made it possible for us
because it's accelerating it so much
it's helping even secular people see the
types of agencies which take over and
you know act through people uh and it's
made it easier at least well I've
noticed it made it easier for me to talk
about these this notion that there are
types of agencies or principalities
power you know Saint Paul uses different
words to talk about these that that kind
of uh let's say have a type of agency
over human behavior and this in some
ways is one of the subjects that ilu has
treated you know in a moment where it
was in some ways very unpopular to talk
about these types of subjects so can you
give us a sense of how he perceived
these these types of transpersonal
agencies
yeah it's a it's a big topic and I have
to be humble to say I'm still sort of
unpacking his perspective and then what
I think about it
um he definitely felt and believed that
there were real principalities and
Powers simply because the Bible treats
them as real
and Marva Don uh is someone who did a
fair amount of work with this topic she
did her whole dissertation on on elul's
view of the powers and principalities
and then wrote some other things about
it
and she highlights that a little
kind of hedged a little bit on what
might be called the ontological being of
powers when it comes to agency and
personification which you know through
Christian tradition when we think of
of of powers is having volitional
dimension
um he he I would say he wasn't like
fully there in his descriptions as
you'll find in other Christian writings
and yet for him they are
they do have independent Force beyond
what you could just study empirically as
a social scientist
um uh just a couple examples for him was
like the power of Mammon which is a
Biblical word related to uh
money and wealth and material things
which have a certain power than over
um our need to protect our ours what we
save
uh it's similar to the way we we kind of
think of a power over someone who is an
addictive or a compulsive relation to
what what enslaves them
and everyone who's in the recovery World
kind of knows that these powers are are
Way Beyond what they themselves can
control
and that's why we use terms like agency
from Beyond because it's it's it's it's
it's the metaphoric language that helps
us be honest about the fact that there's
something greater that's influencing us
yeah in the text uh that I I was reading
uh there's a letter in the from
Jacqueline to Marva Dawn and he seems at
least in some of the parts of the letter
to to
to be wary to be to be cautious like you
said it's as if he's a little
he tends to have a bit of a reductionist
approach to it where he doesn't want to
fully talk about agency but you know let
me just read a a little text from it
here
and so he says he talks about these
powers and he says that is to say they
certainly exist but not as entities
comparable to human and materializable
persons they exist in as much as they
are manifestations and not as beings
thus one finds the evil phenomena the
fact of money of the city of the state
and of technique and these phenomena
reveal the existence of an evil
spiritual power but not as a sort of
powerful Angel reigning over the world
and using money
or the state
and so Satan is the accusation therefore
everywhere there is an accusation
there's Satan but it is not a personage
who provokes and produces the
accusations the accusation exists by
itself
and so
in that I I can see that he's really
struggling he is really struggling to
talk about this
and uh and in some ways I I'm uh
I feel like I don't I kind of understand
especially in the moment where in the
time when he was writing this you know
how he was dealing this but there's a
way in which
in some ways what he's saying about
these agencies and Powers is something
that a reductionist would say about us
about humans you would say there is no
agency there's only the fact of there's
only the actions there's only the cells
there's only the the the the electric
impulses you know in your brain because
you cannot detect true agency through
through material calculation like you
can't
agency uh always appears above let's say
the the material facts and so I was a
little surprised because I I really do
think that someone would take his
argument and apply it to a person and it
would be as valid as the way that he
tries to skirt the problem of
transpersonal agency uh by attributing
only the the factors now I I I I
understand that it's difficult because
because we are we are materialists and
therefore we're not used to thinking
analogically and so when we think when
we think of these angels and we see
these beings with wings we we kind of
freak out because because it bothers us
to think to think that way we we can't
think that even those representations
are always analogical to some to some
other form of yeah to an invisible
agency let's say
yeah this is a deep topic
um I I might kind of come at this topic
from a different angle and I'd like to
throw out the word symbol
um symbol you know Sim Greek for with
Bowl Greek for
throwing something
um you know we get our word ball from
that part of the Greek words that have
the bowl in it so symbol
um to throw with
uh Parable to throw Beyond
diable or diabolic to throw apart
so the the reason I kind of want to
start with symbol is that
in in a way God's effort to reach
humanity and C.S Lewis is kind of big on
this
has to go through symbol to reach us and
that doesn't mean that we we can
deconstruct it and then there's nothing
there we
we
we come to realize it's the necessary
means for one realm that's so
incomprehensible and Beyond to reach us
has to go through metaphor and and
symbol for us to make sense of it
and so I think even when it comes to the
darker powers
all we have is language and symbol in a
way to apprehend it yeah
but like wind like gravity
um like
frequencies now that you know make our
garage door go up and down
we we know that this stuff is like
really happening because we see the
effects
and so
I think that's part of being just
limited human beings is that we have to
learn to
to know that we're really not going to
get that much more than symbol
and yet
uh that's still a rich area for us to
traffic in and what what I kind of find
interesting is that
the dark Powers want to use symbol in a
way that sort of obfuscates what's
really there so powers are always based
and I mean when they have a
kind of a bent agenda they have to have
some kind of lie that's in inherent to
the way they're working in the symbolic
world
because
true symbol is integrity between what's
on the inside and what's on the outside
it's it's kind of the way I think about
Glory
True True Glory is like pure Integrity
of what's on the inside and the outside
like kind of like when you get like uh
like a piece of Amber you know and you
put it up to the Sun and it's just like
this beautiful translucent thing that
you look through and it's solid all the
way through
where whereas a distorted symbol and now
we get into things like idols and
advertising and and words and
stereotypes and things that kind of like
have a certain Force socially they're
they're all predicated on some kind of a
lie they have a duplicitous nature yeah
um and they they function precisely
because their Insight does not have
integrity with the outside the outside
has more of like a grandiosity which we
we kind of like
almost a tribute to things
by by virtue of Association
but they're hollowed out they they
really don't have integrity of meaning
yeah would you say that the very because
this I think would fit well with what it
says which is that the lie in some ways
is the autonomous existence of the thing
itself that is you know the state
presenting itself as the summit of
Authority for example that itself is the
LIE which forces the the disjunction
between this the let's say the outward
appearance or the outward symbol and the
inter interiority of the of what is
symbolized and so it forces you know
when a state believes that it is
all-powerful like in the authoritarian
states that we saw in the 20th century
it is forced to use a religious language
which is not appropriate for itself in
order to apply it to itself because it
is in some ways like the Tower of Babel
taking up the the place of God we could
say yeah and and I I think what fits
with what you're saying is the is the
phrase pretentious hours one of allul's
favorite verses right out of second
Corinthians 10 has this phrase of
pretentious Powers you know that we can
deconstruct and bring captive to the
lordship of Christ and by pretentious it
means it has the appearance
of being very powerful this is this is
what I call the outside manifestation of
a power that presents well like a state
like a nation
um you know like like a new car or
whatever
uh but on the inside has some
contradictions what you're calling a lie
uh there's always an Achilles heel
you know on the inside of of these
duplicitous uh symbols because
they're they're they have to continually
be propped up
um with with falsehoods and narratives
and and things which
um you know again lack the Integrity of
meaning of the way things truly are in
the world
and so one of the ways that I so this is
I think in terms of maybe I can phrase
it this way because I think it relates
to what we're saying now
which is that
seems to
want to portray the negative the
negative in the sense that in some ways
right the crucifixion of Christ the
humiliation of Christ the the you know
the the capacity to embody weakness
subverts the whole structure right and
so in some ways it it it uh it exposes
the powers right in that in the same
similar to the way that the kanijah
talks about and I think that in that
sense he is completely right and there's
something about what he's saying which
Pierce is very truly
where I wonder is that in scripture
there's also a whole other strain which
is the Tabernacle the temple uh you know
and even ezekiel's Third Temple which is
a kind of vision of an eschatological
Temple yeah and and
the same and this image of the son of
man and so for example in Revelation you
have this final image where you have two
so even in the text I was reading you
know he was alluding to the lamb and to
the to the idea of the lamb as this this
insane image right it's like why the
lamb at the summit of the of the
hierarchy right this that's the
subverted image but in the in in
division it's actually two images right
it's it's the son of man and the lamb so
it's the the king judge ruler and the
lamb joined together so there are these
two strange in scripture it's it can
seem contradictory but they're there
right the the vision of the the
Tabernacle where the god asking Moses to
build a tabernacle is is very much using
tropes related to Cain you know the
bezalel uh the way that he's described
as an artificer you know the only other
person called an artificer in scripture
I think is is tubal cane and so it's
like there's this whole other strain and
that's the one that
that that I see a little
um let's say ignore which which would I
think would lead them to say to be
something like a Christian Anarchist
like it's as if all structure is
is dangerous in itself so I don't know
if what do you think of that I'm kind of
poking here but I want to know which
yeah well I'll kind of talk out loud
speaking more more of my thinking than
trying to represent a little yeah okay
okay but then I will come back to him
um but if you think about Renee Gerard's
concept of sacrifice as having cultural
rootage
in the Hebrew tradition as well as the
ancient near East
and from his perspective it slowly is
being
or it's evolving Into A New Perspective
which upends the whole sacrificial
system itself it's it's like a a counter
narrative
that involves non-violence and
forgiveness and relationality and and
upending
so it's it's possible I think that when
you look at liturgical and artistic and
you know the those physical Traditions
that come out of the Old Testament
that those themselves
have a type of evolving understanding so
by the time Jesus is talking to the
woman at the well in in Samaria
he says you know it's hey it's it's
neither that Temple or this Temple
people are going to worship in spirit
and truth I think elul kind of shares a
little bit of that kind of sympathy
where the the temple itself
has has like aspects of legitimate
tradition But ultimately
it it becomes not just replaced by
something spiritual but it actually
becomes sort of
uh there's a tension with it there's a
subverted element and
um
Jesus himself
is using language to confront the temple
institution Itself by by kind of
broadening people's minds into into
these paradoxical ways of thinking that
are trans-cultural
so I I don't know if that's a window in
in talking about that but I think a lure
kind of shares some of that sense of
there's a trajectory just like a
trajectory for Gerard about sacrifice
maybe there is for visual culture too
and I think yeah and so I think that
that's maybe I have a yes and way of
thinking you know not a not a not a this
but this or like I tend to have a yes
and way of thinking and so and so even
in the story of Christ you have those
images and then you also have the fact
that he cleansed the the temple he
wanted to purify the the space that that
God had established then I also think of
the eschatological vision the image of
the Heavenly Jerusalem is very powerful
because
it seems to solve the problem because
the way that it's presented is is that
the Kings the kings of all Nations you
know offer their Crown up into the
Heavenly City and all the glory of all
the nations are elevated into the
Heavenly Jerusalem and so it's not that
the nations are destroyed it's not that
the Kings don't exist is that there
exists in the proper order
so whatever whatever particular Glory a
nation has is given up to something
higher and that's its Glory actually
right it's like that is what is glorious
whatever it can offer up and whatever it
doesn't hold on to itself and and tries
to to you know like like the kind of
the kind of dangerous nationalism that
we can see that that is actually a kind
of way in which all this participates on
this so there isn't a there isn't just a
negative part there's also this kind of
positive way that we can that
Civilization that art that culture that
that that that that Authority that all
these things part can participate
ultimately in the Kingdom
yeah I I think I I would affirm that and
there's
there's a affirming incarnational
blessing of of things that that are with
Integrity reflect the nature of God and
the the intended
you know creation that was set out for
us
um
and at the same time Jesus is the great
disturber of everything and every
culture that does not align with with
all of that yeah that's kind of the way
that I I tend to I tend to see it myself
yeah it's so so in terms of in terms of
how do you feel that speaks now because
you know we're seeing in some ways the
the radical acceleration of
technification you know everybody's
talking about AI right now it's it's
wild because it it's as if now these
principalities and powers are almost
like appearing in front of us and so and
so what do you what do you think
yeah well just as an aside I'm I'm a
real fan of C.S Lewis's Ransom trilogy
um and the third one That Hideous
Strength is you know you can get away
with saying things in fiction that you
can't always convey a non-fiction and so
I I just think that that's a great
example for us to think into
some of the trends that that we're
wrestling with now when when you think
about how powers are related to
institutions and whatnot
um for allul I personally think that one
of his most important books for our
current time is the technological Bluff
uh it it in many ways uh is the third of
a Trilogy if you start with the
technological Society you know that he
wrote in the 50s and then in the 70s he
wrote the technological system which
adds some new perspective on his
original thesis and then thirdly he
wrote the technological Bluff and by
Bluff he's he's talking about how
technique driven
um methods in our society present well
to provide Solutions even uses the the
word salvation that at times you know
because of this problem this technology
is going to save us from what not
and yet the bluff is we really don't
know exactly how
the
the rollouts are going to look we don't
know what all the effects are he uses
terms like
um consequences are unforeseeable
they're unpredictable
sometimes even unmanaged unmanageable
yeah
and because we have such a high General
faith in technology we think that's the
only way to really solve something you
know we we have a a pandemic which
arguably comes out of a technological
malleol
um but now we have to find a
technological solution to to deal with
it well now that presents some
additional Fallout challenges and this
this is the bluff that he says
we need to call if we're really gonna uh
not let ourselves be in these cycles of
technological uh soteriology yeah yeah
yeah and one of the things that elude
seems to present which is very powerful
is that in some ways
what happens in a technological State
when what happens when the technological
Takes Over The Narrative is that it's
only means that matter that that in some
ways we don't even know what the goal is
the the it's only the implementation of
means which seems to be the very purpose
of society itself and it's almost like
you said it's as if and then the the
side effects of the implementation
create new needs and new problems that
have to be sorted out by the
implementation of more and more uh
efficient and Technical means and so
it's like it makes you feel like you're
moving and you're moving towards
something but there is no there is no
end point it decides what more technical
efficient things like you know what what
is the purpose of all this where are we
going well when we we get away from yeah
healthy sustainable systems that have
give and take and balance and and
whatnot
yeah there's a sense in which we
you know for example like the the
the idea that this the Techni the
techniques this technicity you know uh
is supposed to make us happy I guess
it's I guess maybe that's like the best
thing that you can or like the most
positive idea you can makes it easier
maybe in order for us I'm trying to to
be generous to the to this kind of run
towards technicity to make us to make
life easier to make to make things for
us to do the things that we care about
which are not
related to life or something like that
like that Leisure and and and and and
pleasure like that but but we can see
through like the increase in depression
and the increase in kind of
a kind of Madness that people are
falling into you know especially as as
identity starts to fragment you know
they they don't know where to look for
meaning
yeah and I I think this aligns very well
with with uh C.S Lewis's abolition of
man yeah another one of my favorites
because he in the same way you're
talking about means separated from ends
uh that fits well with what Lewis calls
um
you know agendas of progress being
untethered from traditional ethics yeah
because ethics are ultimately about
understanding our best ends and then
um balancing ourselves in in relation to
those they have a claim on on society to
create good ends but once once you
remove traditional ethics from the realm
of
applied science then you can see how the
means becomes more dominance it's the
same way in the artistic and
image culture where the form begins to
dominate over content and meaning
similar application there yeah you see
that I mean advertisement is the
ultimate example of that you know and
and uh
I mean it's it's it's fascinating I
don't know if I mean I for sure C.S
Lewis had that intuition very much so
which is that in some ways the the
increase in man wanting to free himself
from Transcendent you know attachment
the the desire for man to kind of
fulfill his own destiny to fulfill his
own will and to to kind of fulfill his
own desire for power uh ultimately leads
very surprised it's not that surprising
but it can seem surprising to some to an
anti-human uh narrative ultimately where
in some ways you know we're seeing it
now in the more extreme version of the
environmental narrative where it's
almost as if humans are just parasites
in the world and that they you know all
they do is consume and it'd be better if
there were fewer of them in the world
and you see it now with AI as well this
kind of idea that we that you know we
need to be transcended ourselves like
we're going to give birth something that
will ultimately destroy us or consume it
percent there's almost like a suicidal
ecstasy it's very it's very disturbing
to see that that's at the end of this
this kind of uh desire for technical
power but I know Phil had Insight on
that if you know that he had he had kind
of foreseen something like that
well I see what what you're saying as
requiring social compliancy
in other words you you can only go in
that direction if you if you don't allow
for Dissent and that everyone has what
might be called a shared reality
um and uh since you're in Canada I'll
reference an interesting video that
comes out by
um Horizons Canada
uh which has a Tower of Babel Motif in
it
and what's really interesting about this
The Narrative because it's all about
where technology and and Humanity find
um a way to work together for a better
future
um but it has a Tower of Babel image in
it you know that's that's all about you
know people all coming together for one
big project
and it reverses the narrative because
God is now the uh the antagonist
in a scenario where it's good for people
to come together think alike share one
language and create a better shared
future
it's unfortunate that that project was
thwarted and God scattered people
laterally back you know back into their
creature Hood yeah and this is something
that has been going on for a while the
you know the building one of the main
buildings for the European Union I think
it's your one of these globalists
Association is literally designed based
on brugel's Tower of Babel and and that
and when the European Union decided to
kind of meet one of the posters they put
out was a huge poster of brugal's Tower
of Babel and it was like you know we're
gonna basically we're gonna finish the
project you know we're gonna finally do
this right and you know the those 16th
century artists there's so many Babel
painters
uh many of them show the tower
incomplete as a both social and
Theological statement yeah
um because because the the fact that it
was not completed
is itself a commentary on on the uh
you know the the false efforts to to try
to uh build something independent of God
yeah and that's the right that's the
right way to see it is that to imagine
that anything is complete
is the sin in itself right yeah do you
imagine that anything can be
self-contained and complete is a is the
is the era of idolatry so here's a nice
way to bring our topic back to powers
and speaking of 16th century did you
know where the phrase Hideous Strength
comes from no no I don't know it's a
Tower of Babel phrase okay uh David
Lindsay a poet from 1555 wrote uh About
That Hideous Strength
um and the shadow that it casted six
miles in length mm-hmm
and so this is uh Lewis as a medieval
and Renaissance uh scholar of literature
uh comes across this poem recognizes
this phrase Hideous Strength as
um about the archetypal force from the
Babel project and and then uses that all
through That Hideous Strength and of
course the nice which is such a playful
jester-like uh acronym you know for the
Institute of
of the technocrats
because they're aspiring upward you know
to have
uh you know to build a utopian society
they poke through the heavens so to
speak just like my hands sort of poking
above the box here
and without them knowing it that opens
up a portal for other uh benign
Celestial powers to come down to earth
and to support uh the you know the team
that's fighting against the bad side
so they brought down on their heads
their own demise yeah this is a
beautiful image to say that powers have
a duplicitous nature because on the
outside again they present well with
with great
uh Force and and everything but on the
inside there's an insecurity and a lie
and a contradiction uh which which means
that they're they ultimately bear the
seeds of their own destruction yeah and
I mean I'm interested in knowing about
this as well if because one of the
things I haven't seen in in also is a
mention of angels that is there is a
whole Vision in scripture of the Divine
Council you know this is something that
is becoming I think with good reason
more more popular and talked about today
the idea that that and and the way that
it was recuperated in Christian
mysticism right for example in in
Dionysus is uh Divine hierarchy he he
literally uses the words that Saint Paul
uses to describe what he's talking about
in terms of negative influences that
that that uh that oppress us he uses
them to talk to them about them in terms
of their positive you know as like a as
levels of of manifestation from the
Divine down into human so Throne Powers
all these things are used by Dionysus to
to describe the way that God kind of
descends into the world and so has he
did has he talked about that like the
the the the reality of angels let's say
in the New Testament as well
I I think he kind of hedged on that you
know you got to understand that he's
he's starts out as a Marxist and so his
his notion of power and forces like akin
to the fetishism of Commodities yeah
yeah and and uh and so ultimately when
when elul has interest in powers and
principalities biblically
he's interested in their function not
their ontological being yeah so he's not
denying their existence
but I think this goes back to the symbol
thing he he recognizes that
uh that everything is symbolic whether
it's the New Jerusalem or or winged
beings or or whatever
as a way to help us
grasp that there's something there
that's additional to our
you know our human cultural realm yeah
but even in like even in terms of
functionality and if you think about
Saint John in in the in the Book of
Revelation when he addresses the angels
of the Cities right and so there's a
sense in which in that case the angel of
the city right or the the principality
of the city is not seen in a negative
way it's just seen as you know the it's
a kind of a a place where the identity
of the city comes together in its agency
and so I address this this angel in a in
a positive way not in a negative way
yeah yeah
so I mean because I think that that
image that you just gave us of the Tower
of Babel poking through you know and
then the surprise that it lets in you
know uh benign principalities or good
principalities I think that that's
something that we're already seeing and
it's very interesting so a good example
is that during uh during during covid
especially in places where the the the
power of the state was felt very
strongly all of a sudden it's like it
kind of exposed certain things which
were already there hidden in certain
capacities that the state had that
people didn't realize that that were
there and then all of a sudden this
Crisis get you know exposes and makes
real the capacity for the state to
really control us you know in in ways
that we didn't think were possible both
through narrative through kind of inner
propaganda like using tools of
propaganda inside our the country but
then also real power of like you know
when I was in quarantine the policeman
showed up in my at my door right it's
like these are real these are real uh
Power uh steps uh but another thing that
happened is that it in seeing that
agency and in seeing the the state act
with such Force and and
and feeling I was like nobody's
controlling it right exactly like an
agency it's like why is it happening all
over the world
and there's nobody in charge of this and
it's nobody with like that is like is
there's no like Evil Genius sitting
there rubbing his hands and and making
it happen it's just it's just like it's
it's a form of
it is a pattern which is laying itself
in the world the reaction to that for a
lot of people was conversion
you know like in the Orthodox church we
have seen a massive wave of converts at
the end of covid and I'm talking
parishes doubling tripling uh all young
people that through this desire of the
state to gain absolute power they were
able to perceive something about how the
world Works uh that made them want to to
to attach themselves to something higher
you know
and that probably did not happen as much
in the mainline denominations
I don't know I don't know I just know
about of course my own my own my own
church and so why would you I don't know
why would you think that wouldn't have
happened in the mainline domination
denomination for example because most
Mainline denominations lean a little
more Progressive and liberal at least in
the United States and so they were more
compliant to not gather
and uh in many cases they were whittled
down more
and many of them are struggling more so
with not just attendance but leadership
transitions uh vision of what their
Church you know direction is
where whereas in in churches which might
not have
struggled as much with that sense of
um compliancy to official narratives
there's probably more of of a sense of
resistance and alternative community
uh and perhaps that becoming a an
attractive magnet for other people
seeking Community yeah and even the even
like the I think
because one of the things that happens
in these totalizing uh patterns is that
they there's a sense in which we need to
be reduced to individuals like we need
to be reduced to just dots you know
without without uh competing allegiances
you could say to the to the massive
power of the state and that and then
reducing people to lonely you know to
like you're just a lonely especially
those that didn't have families and only
guys lonely women you know sitting there
in front of Netflix for a whole year I
think it also made the problem very
acute where people realize no actually I
need intermediary
uh communities I need real connected uh
places where I physically go and talk to
people and have and and do that with uh
with something that is Meaningful and
and not just uh not just uh yeah not
just arbitrary Louisville talks about
that as a key priority in his book uh
presence in the modern world really his
first major book written in the mid-40s
and in contrast to institutional systems
that want to have a one-way
communication to kind of can control
things uh he he talks about needing to
be with neighbors needing to have real
conversations uh prizing localism
um
you know and later of course his famous
phrases you know where dialogue ends
propaganda begins so he had a pretty
strong uh
advocacy for those local real life
relationship uh Dynamics as a way to
kind of maintain a type of resistance in
the world yeah so maybe that's a good
place to transition and and and let's
move into the last question that I have
for you is maybe you can tell people
about your work and and how you see what
kind of solutions you see for modern
people in this this increasingly
technified world and also increasing
centralized authorities how do you see
people
finding real-life solutions for the for
their lives and for their families for
the people around them
yeah it's a compelling question and my
my primary work is in the field of
restorative justice and conflict
resolution for about 25 years and it's
it's a great calling
and
you know one of the things I've observed
as a facilitator is that there's almost
a paralysis of dialogue in in our
Western cultures uh people just having
more uh caution and reservation about
having hard conversations with each
other because they're not maybe maybe
they're not sure how the other person is
thinking or how they'll react or maybe
they do know how the other person is
thinking and they're afraid that it'll
cause a rift in the Friendship so
whether it's red blue issues or pandemic
issues or race issues or uh cultural
correctness issues whatever it is we're
experiencing a type of paralysis
um that's deadening healthy Dialogue on
so many levels whether it's family and
interpersonal or friends or co-workers I
mean I I know uh University teachers
that feel more afraid
to to just freely say things or choose
things within their curriculum because
they feel like there's eyes watching
them not not just from above but
students who who will Who will say you
know I I didn't feel safe when when that
content was presented without warning I
have a friend who lost her job because
of that of that very thing
um without any dignifying learning
conversation from both sides
so practically and positively
the way I see dialogue opening is in the
word story
usually when we think of civil discourse
we think of people you know having
healthy debate and and there's a good
place for that
but it's not necessarily A starting
point so when I talk about story I'm
talking about people getting into the
experiential realm of what they're
really observing and noticing and living
through and maybe some hardships that
they've gone through and just narrating
that across the divides to people that
might have oppositional perspective
and what that does is it gets people out
of what I call their head Zone where
they tend to be defensive they want to
win arguments and persuade people and
Into the Heart Zone
where we tend to think more about our
common Humanity with others the the
heart zone is where we listen better
where we apologize where we have some
humility curiosity uh and it brings us
into these story realms
uh so that that's a big part of what I
do in my workshops now with different
groups is I'll talk about what are
skills and structures that help
conversation shift away from head zones
Into the Heart zones where there's kind
of a bonding potential and that doesn't
mean everything just stays in kind of
this feeling
story Zone yeah it actually creates a
foundation for people with differing
views to then come back into the head
zones and have more capacity and more
trust to really
have iron sharpen iron at that point
yeah because I think we still need those
hard logic based conversations
but we're just not able to start there
so we we have to have foundations of of
shared understanding shared bonding
shared appreciation for what other
people have gone through and then find
ways to come back to the the more
debatable issues yeah and I think I
think that what you've just said is key
because in some ways
what we see it seems like what we see is
an excess of both and a new capacity to
bridge because what you often see The
Clash and and I see it you see it even
in the in the sad online world is is
someone coming with a story perspective
and then someone answering with the
facts logic perspective and that can go
wrong in many ways in the sense that
maybe the person who's just telling the
story just wants to tell their stories
that you understand where they're coming
from sometimes the person telling their
story confuses the spaces so they think
that their story is is an argument for
the head head place and then and then
there's a misalignment but the idea of
of both exploring both and understanding
the difference between the two and
saying like you know of course we should
like we if we know each other then that
that bound that that basic uh place for
trust is set and then we can like you
said then we can talk about the
difficult issues in terms of more in
terms of of uh of how reasonable things
are and and what makes sense in terms of
what we're doing uh
so so that no I think that's that seems
like a great approach
um
well Ted thank you so much for this this
conversation you know uh the the
I appreciated you that you went there
with me because as you saw like my this
my my relationship with dilute is like a
50 50 relationship and that's maybe why
in some ways I haven't uh talked about
him so much on my channel but I think
for people watching it's a good it's a
good place to to LEAP into a little uh
especially as someone who had very deep
insight into something into all the
problems we're dealing with now in terms
of of technification and also in terms
of of of State Powers becoming
all-powerful uh and how as Christians we
can deal with that so thanks a lot for
your time
yeah I'm really really thankful to be
here and I just want to tack on one
short piece that kind of brings powers
and story together as a theme the
counter narrative for elul
with respect to the Tower of Babel
is Philippians 2 where Jesus empties
himself
not wanting to take on The Importance of
Being like a Greek Roman god with lots
of status but becomes a servant and it
ends up dying
that's the reversal of the Tower of
Babel impulse to to be autonomous
and I think that that incarnational
story uh in elulse talks about this as a
juxtaposition numerous times in his
writings
uh validates the whole notion that we
live in a real world we live in a messy
world we live in a visual world and so
to be able to engage without the same
power dynamics uh it really does have
validation in that story
because it's it's it's the ultimate
symbol of God reaching us yeah and it's
the surprising image of the one who does
that you know with that with the
headboard which says that he's the king
simultaneously that kind of simultaneous
Clash of imagery where he both envies
himself and is raised up to the highest
you know he goes into death but then
enters into the holy place like it's a
yeah the story of the Cross just kills
you every time you think about it it's
so it's it it just smashes everything
together so seeing the world through the
cross is definitely the way to solve the
problem of of principalities and powers
and how you know
the highest gives itself to the lowest
that's the best way to understand true
Christian hierarchy and true Christian
power so Ted thanks this has been great
well it's a delight to to come converse
with you and and kind of see where our
conversation leads us
all right